Kate let me go back to your first
conversations with Todd had he sent you
a script had he described what he was
working on where did your contact with
Todd begin and what was his pitch to you
well we met 10 years ago
um he'd been writing a scripture John
Didion and um yeah and so I
we talked about working together in that
for one reason or another that hadn't
happened and obviously it's been a long
time since Todd has made a film and I'm
so grateful he's he's back in the race
again I mean you know on the track and
um he sent me the script and there was
no contact at all and I think it's it
speaks to him wanting to get an actor's
response to things he didn't want to
send a cover letter he doesn't want to
tell me anything about it and um and so
the conversation when we began to speak
about it it was intensely practical
because there was so much to do it
wasn't until we actually got on set and
started to to
um to deconstruct the scenes that we got
to the sort of the metaphysical layers
or in rehearsal we we did all of the
sort of the backstory stuff and I think
that comes from him being an actor is he
wants he doesn't
um you know I then graduated of course I
had so many questions uh for him during
the process of the preparation but he
tended to the Practical did he answer
those questions or does he like actors
to have some doubt about certain things
if you want to know everything does he
hold something back or do you want to
know everything he can tell you if
there's a not I mean
I really want to have everything tied
down and answered and this this film I
think is an experience I hope asks more
questions that it answers and that was
that was part of the process it's a
rehearsal movie and I mean art imitated
life in that way the the process of
making it was just so in invigorating
and and uh challenging not only
physically but sort of emotionally and
and metaphysically I think yeah Nina how
would you describe or how did you talk
to Todd about your character's
relationship Sharon with Lydia because
it is almost as much a relationship as
it is maybe a transaction that there's
something going on that's understood
maybe more by your character than Lydia
how would you describe what your what
your conversations with Todd were about
the nature of the relationship we see it
but what were your questions about how
they get along and why they're still
together
yeah at the beginning for example when I
read the script the first time
there was nothing in the script about
any transactional
stuff you know between between the two
and the more I I read the script and I
thought about Sharon and I then started
we started to rehearse and I spoke with
with Todd about the scenes
I kind of felt Sharon is not a victim
you know she is as much in this as Lydia
and maybe
what makes Lydia so controversial let's
say is something that Sharon really
loves and really likes and maybe she
enhances it in places and so I could
find in the script little points that
actually hinted me in this put me in
this direction like when she says in the
first scene our daughters really uh you
know having trouble and she comes back
with bruised chins and so someone's
doing something to her you can say that
very innocently but if you know whom
you're talking to you know she's gonna
do something about it you know so you
know and then she does something that I
didn't see I had no idea you know right
and but something and she comes home and
she's fine you know oops you know so it
it it it it it told me oh she she is
pattern is in in how much are people who
are around people in the powerful
position
how much do they want to keep this
system up you know and how much can they
benefit from that power exactly do they
benefit but but they can hide she can't
hide you know so that I found so
immensely interesting once we got that
out
um we we we try to figure that out more
and more but the base for me was truly
that they are a couple in love and that
they've been through a lot but also
where they find each other is really in
the art of making music together you
know if people have watched the credits
closely you would have seen cello solo
by Sophie cower
Sophie how many movies have you made
before this
[Applause]
zero first film how many times you
played the cello before this
uh since I was eight years old so a bit
of a so tell us where where you are
professionally you're still studying is
that right yeah I'm halfway through my
bachelor's degree
um so right after this I'll be going
back to school
um but uh no it's
uh really surreal I mean I still haven't
quite understood what has happened and
every time I see a film I'm just like is
that really did I really do this what on
there and I get to work with these
amazing people like really everyone the
best of the best top of the game both as
in both in terms of all the the cast and
the crew and then the actual musicians
and yeah there is an incredible team
involved and you know Todd as well
um and I don't quite know when I'll kind
of wake up really
um maybe I won't maybe that's a good
thing I don't know Marco you are setting
a lot of this movie is set in a
performance space in a hall
how do you go about finding a hall that
you could shoot in and that worked for
the
vaguely fictional orchestra that your
character is conducting
well that was kind of the first
conversation we had when we're closer
there was one of the first conversations
we had when we were talking about the
movie is where like how do we pull off
the concert hall that had to do like
Kate mentioned it's the rehearsal movie
so we spend a lot of time
in in the concert hall itself in the
main performing Hall but we also had all
the other
um parts of the concert hall like the
hallways the backstage the offices and
all that stuff to to service
um we looked at all the possible concert
halls in Germany and um found one in
Dresden that would kindly cooperate with
us and we shot in there for nine days so
we had to
have quite a big slot that was only
possible to to achieve that because it
was still covet and they closed down and
um funny enough through
um because we learn in or we've seen the
movie that
um the orchestras they are kind of a
democratic body they have to decide on
what piece to play and
and so we had to go on sessions before
to
present the project to the orchestra and
um ask them whether they whether they're
all like all the musicians are prepared
to take part in the movie
and whether or not they wanted to play
the piece of music exactly wow yeah it's
like bench rights they get they get to
decide yeah they also like really it was
about do they want to play Marla 5.
there was the first conversation we had
with him being I want to ask you your
creative process when you're reading a
script I assume that's where you start
and how story speaks to you first and
then character and at what point do you
start having ideas about design and at
what point does the actor become part of
that design process
well I think at
um
in contemporary costume design for me
the actors are fundamental
um
I base my ideas on the actors I love to
work with them I love to listen to them
of course first I listened to the script
I read it and we had a very specific
script and we had a very specific
director and I was lucky because I
connected very quickly with him
and I was also very lucky because I know
Kate so that also helps and I had worked
already once with Nina's and I know her
from her German like we are both German
um for me in this
movie
it is not about only the costume design
that I try to help them and to dress
them I really try to be like a company
or in what they want to achieve and and
it's for example I thought there's a lot
of in the movie about Temple the
musician the temple how Kate walked how
Nida Nina walks and how taught is and
actually I thought like for me because a
lot of costumes I just decided in the
morning
um and so in the when I came to set I
first I had like to get the tempo of
tort that is very special to find out so
how is the scene today look at his
design the interior is there everything
like
interesting that I can capture and then
transmit it to the actors meanwhile they
are getting dressed and so I go perhaps
first to address Nina and she has her
own Tempo and I have like to adapt to
her so that I can support her and then I
get to Kate and she is another Tempo
again and for example the person who
dressed Kate she said to me that when
you are together with Kate it looks like
you are dancing around the the rack like
I never know what your GoPro is going to
do and what where you end up because I
always had more options because this was
so important in the movie it's such a
personal story and it's also like
the story was growing with us how much
power really did she have there were so
many questions
and we didn't know the answers and
perhaps we never we didn't want to know
the answers we just wanted to experience
it
um Mark I want to ask you about editing
it almost feels like there's so much
musical language in the dialogue of this
film does Todd also speak in a musical
language when he's edited in terms of
movements in terms of tempo in terms of
crescendos or do you have a language
that's not at all related to music
it is a
it is a mutual understanding of what the
material gives us and how we can build
it uh I mean we don't pronounce the
words but we feel them while building up
the story and while building up the
scenes
tell us about a scene that was
I won't say Troublesome but difficult to
solve the scene that you maybe kept
coming back to throwing different
assemblies together to find out
how it worked or how it worked best
to be honest the most difficult and
demanding scene is a scene that didn't
make it at all from
but this is very often the case it's uh
it's maybe that's why I didn't make it
it was you couldn't solve it
no we could solve it it would be a a
nice piece of a very short short film
um but it didn't have the space in the
film because it was too distracting from
where Lydia was at the very moment in
time
Monica
Bina Marco Sophie Nina Cape thank you so
much for joining us thank you thank you
very much
[Applause]